hey guys dr. Berg here in this video
we're going to show you how to get rid
of sciatica now a lot of times the way
people treats attica is completely
backwards and so if you apply what I'm
going to show you it will be amazing the
only thing is you need some help to do
this
with another person but I will show you
how to do it on yourself
it's just more difficult okay so let's
let's show you how to do it
okay so let's pretend that this person
has sciatic pain on the right side now
you have to realize that sciatic nerve
comes from this point right through the
butt out down the back of your hamstring
all the way down through this way if you
have pain on the outside through here or
the front that's not sciatica so sonica
is a big nerve it's about the width of
my thumb all the way down here so this
is what you do if you have Sonic on the
right side okay the static nerve comes
right out of here you want to work on
the opposite side okay so you'll be
pressing the opposite side of that nerve
so you'll so you'll start right here and
there's a sacrum that comes here and
you're going to work right on the site
okay it's called the sciatic notch and
we're going to press in there right in
there and we're going to trace down the
nerve we're going to trace down the
nerve like this okay and you're just
going to stimulate the nerve on the
opposite side it's going to get rid of
this side why because they're on a
circuit this is a stuck standing wave
and the way to get rid of it is to work
on this side again this is one of those
things where you don't have to believe
me just do it and you'll see it works we
press right down we come right down the
center of that leg and you trace it all
the way down you can do it slowly and
work all the way down all the way down
all the way down through here now what
happens when you press on the opposite
side it's going to be very very tender
it's going to be very probably twice as
painful is this side that hurts and so
I'm not going to get into why that's
tender but you're going to look for the
tenderness so you want to go within that
persons tolerance and just kind of work
that that nerve and then what you'll do
is you'll you'll work on this side and
you'll ask okay where does it hurt on
this side and they might say well now it
shifted down here okay then we can just
do the opposite side over here okay or
maybe it's like lower on the calf then
we do the opposite side through here so
the key is never ever ever ever work on
the same side as the sciatic nerve is
work on the opposite side and you want
to get the mirror image start from the
right through here work all the way down
and you might want to spend like a
couple of minutes working each spot all
the way down to the the foot okay so now
one more thing if you're going to
actually do it on yourself you're going
to be laying on your back and you'll be
sitting okay and you need a tennis ball
you need a tennis ball or a racquet ball
and you're going to sit right on the
this point right through here and let
let that little tennis ball hit this
point and then inch it down slowly inch
it down slowly and sit down and you're
actually sitting on this one little ball
and you kind of inch down the static
nerve but I wanted to show you what you
have to do so you can do it yourself but
you'll be sitting on the ball letting
gravity put pressure along that point
and you can just work all the way down
here all the way down here so you're
basically sitting on a chair or
something with the little ball sitting
up on the nerve and you're just pushing
it all the way down and then with the
calf you could massage yourself the
bottom part all the way down to the foot
so it's a little more difficult but you
could do it yourself so that's the
technique to fix sciatica